un record à 58 milles dollars puis une
chute de 20% les jours suivants il faut
avoir le coeur bien accroché pour suivre
le bitcoin la star décrite aux monnaies
qui pèse désormais quelques 1000
milliards de dollars mais le bitcoin
n'est pas le seul à flamber la bourse et
l'immobilier reste à des niveaux très
élevés malgré la crise alors sommes-nous
dans un monde de bulles
comment est-ce que tout cela peut finir
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir sélénites aux
échos ce soir bonsoir
jacques bienvenu bonsoir c'est pas dit
alors jacques que se passe-t-il sur
certains marchés d'actifs comme les
crypto monnaie est ce que des petites
bulles sont en train de se former
oui c'est tout à fait évident alors on a
déjà le problème de la bourse qui est à
un niveau tout à fait historiquement
hauts
et puis vous avez parlé évidemment du
marché du bitcoin le bitcoin il est
aujourd'hui à un niveau qui est dix fois
supérieur à son niveau de l'année
dernière et on a aussi le marché de
l'immobilier sur lesquels les prix sont
actuellement extrêmement élevé donc oui
effectivement on peut se poser la
question de savoir si on n'est pas face
à de multiples bulles qui sont en train
de se constituer dans l'économie alors
jacques prenons les choses dans l'ordre
on va commencer par le marché du bitcoin
que se passe-t-il pourquoi déjà une
telle flambée alors le marché de bitcoin
il faut le rappeler
on est parti de rien il ya évidemment
quelques années on était autour de 5000
$ l'année dernière où à la fin de
l'hiver 2019 2020 et puis maintenant on
est monté à quasiment cinquante huit
mille dollars à un moment donné avant de
connaître une chute qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
et là ça veut dire deux choses 1 le
bitcoin est devenu un actif un actif
comme les autres s'est pas réellement
une monnaie mais c'est un actif dans
lequel les gens cherchent à placer leur
argent
le deuxième point c'est encore plus
important c'est un actif qui est
excessivement spéculatifs
on le voit bien on vous
bien que aujourd'hui les courts du
bitkom sont particulièrement erratique
dont oui on est là sur un phénomène de
très grandes spéculations alors les
cours de la bourse
eux ne montre-t-il pas une évolution
comparable
oui oui stéphanie tout à fait on est en
fait en présence de la même situation
alors on pourrait penser que la bourse
allez refléter d'abord la crise
sanitaire que nous connaissons à l'écran
refléter aussi le fait que l'économie
reste aujourd'hui embourbé dans les
conséquences de cette crise sanitaire
que nous ne sortirons de cette crise au
mieux qu'en 2022 pas du tout après avoir
digéré en deux trois semaines
le choc de la crise sanitaire il ya un
an nous avons continué à monter c'est à
dire que nous avons vu les cours de la
bourse
continuer à monter et aujourd'hui si on
prend le dow jones à wall street
on est sur des niveaux qui sont
historiquement élevé on a bien le
sentiment qu'il y ait une déconnexion
entre les mouvements des marchés
financiers les mouvements de la bourse
et l'économie réelle
et ça c'est un signal extrêmement clair
d'une situation spéculative et vous nous
dit jacques que l'immobilier est
également concernée oui tout à fait
alors pas partout si on prend le cas en
france on voit que cela concerne
essentiellement l'île de france la
région parisienne la région lyonnaise
mais ce que l'on retient c'est que les
cours montent de manière tout à fait
considérable que ces cours ont continué
de monter avec le début de la pandémie
bon ils ont tellement monté qu'à partir
d'un moment ils ont commencé à se tasser
et abc mais de manière extrêmement
légère qu'est ce que ça signifie là
encore on voit bien il y a beaucoup
d'argent qui cherchent à s'investir il
va s'investir essentiellement dans
l'immobilier et sur des régions où les
prix sont
déjà très élevé c'est typiquement la
caractéristique d'un marché spéculatif
alors jacques quelle est la cause de
cette désordre la première cause il faut
le dire ce sont les politiques des
banques centrales prenons le cas de la
banque centrale européenne ce qui est
très net c'est que la banque centrale
européenne qui maintenait l'année
dernière à lyon jusqu'au début de la
pandémie qui maintenait de toutes les
manières une politique très accommodante
et bien elle a littéralement ouvert les
vannes depuis la fin du mois de février
le début du mois de mars 2020 donc il ya
exactement un an
et qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit que de
ce fait la logique de deux montées de la
masse monétaire devient absolument
insensé on était parti de taux qui était
de l'ordre de 5 à 6%
on se retrouve aujourd'hui à des taux
qui sont de l'ordre de 13% et qu'est ce
qu'il ya derrière et bien il ya derrière
le fait que la bce a maintenu il ya même
augmenter son programme de rachat des
titres qui ciblait les banques et
surtout que la bce a mis sur pied un
programme spécial ce qui s'appelle le
ppp
le programme d'urgence de réaction face
à la con déni ou la bce achète des
centaines et des centaines de milliards
d'euros de titres aux états donc on voit
bien là encore on est face à une
politique qui est devenu extrêmement
laxiste extrêmement je dirais pro
activité de la part de la banque
centrale européenne alors jacques est ce
que cela est propre à l'europe
non non non non il faut le dire ce sont
des politiques que l'on retrouve dans
l'ensemble des banques centrales
qu'il s'agisse de la banque d'angleterre
de la banque du japon
et si on regarde la réserve fédérale eh
bien on va voir que la cour était est à
peu près la même
on avait une
a sion qui était importante mais qui
restait quand même relativement modérée
jusqu'au mois de février 2001 et depuis
le mois de février 2020 bien là encore
on voit une augmentation extrêmement
rapide de la masse monétaire qui
correspond tout simplement au près et au
refinancement des banques
que fait très largement la réserve
fédérale
donc là aussi on voit que l'on est en
présence de politique générale de la
part des banques centrales qui consiste
à injecter massivement de la monnaie
dans l'économie
alors vous avez aussi parlé de bulles
mais ne va-t-il pas y avoir
jacques de l'inflation également ça
serait d'une certaine manière la réponse
traditionnelle
sauf qu ce que l'on oublie c'est que
pour qu'une création monétaire à ce
niveau là puisse provoquer de
l'inflation
encore faudrait-il que nos économies
soit si ce n'est au plein emploi mais
soit disons dans des situations qui soit
relativement propre du plein emploi
ce n'est pas du tout le cas en réalité
nous sommes aujourd'hui avec des
situations où les niveaux d'activité des
économies restent relativement faibles
et vont rester faible encore pour les 2
3 ans qui viennent
donc ce qui veut dire que le risque
d'inflation en terre le dirai et des
housses de la hausse des prix à la
consommation n'est pas le risque
principal ce risque sera au pire très
modéré par contre ce que cela veut dire
c'est que on a une masse d'argent qui
cherche aujourd'hui à s'investir
évidemment il y a un problème parce que
les taux d'intérêt étant très bas que ce
soit en europe ou aux états unis
et bien cet argent cherche désespérément
des marchés sur lesquels ils pourraient
s'investir et un démarche est possible
eh bien ce sont ces marchés un petit peu
exotiques comme le marché du bitcoin
comme la bourse évidemment qui est moins
exotique qui est qui est plus
traditionnel ou encore comme
l'immobilier
alors en conclut jean-jacques va-t-on
assister à une volatilité toujours plus
forte ces actifs
oui oui c'est effectivement un des
risques auxquels on peut être confrontés
on peut avoir avec la création de ce
type de bulles une situation où d'un
marché à l'autre on aurait des
phénomènes de contamination ce que l'on
voit aujourd'hui sur le bitcoin pourrait
finir par contaminer d'autres marchés
comme les bourses par exemple et qu'est
ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire que en
réalité nous sommes dans une situation
où les marchés financiers les marchés
d'actifs son passé moi l'expression sous
stéroïdes
ils sont dopés par la politique des
banques centrales
mais inversement les banques centrales
elles mêmes sont devenues dépendantes
des marchés financiers et sont donc
d'une certaine manière
contraint de continuer à les alimenter
personne ne veut prendre le risque de
provoquer aujourd'hui une crise majeure
sur quelques marchés d'actifs que ce
soit très merci jacques en tout cas pour
cette envie de tempête annoncé au moins
on sera prévenus merci à vous